hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the virtues of
faith hope and charity or love in Latin
Caritas or a more have been looked at by
Christians as being central to the
Christian life ruling from from early on
and they supplement the other virtues as
well and some is going to have a
treatment of these very close to the end
of the monologue ship in which she
brings them together he doesn't tell us
quite so much about hope he's already
told us quite a bit about love now we're
very interested in what he does have to
say about hope but especially much more
about what he has to say about faith
fides and when Anselm tells us first in
Monta loggia chapter 75 which is a very
short chapter is that the human being is
unable to engage in the striving that
comes out of naturally loving and desire
desiring god to the degree that one
ought to if it despairs if it thinks
that it's not possible for if it has an
effective orientation towards that I'm
attaining God so it needs the opposite
of despair which is hope and you know
that's pretty much all that he has to
say
at that point just tell us plenty of
other things about hope in many other
places in his worse where it gets very
interesting is his discussions about
faith or feedings now before we go into
this when people use this word faith
they're they're often using it in a you
might say equivocal sense or perhaps an
analogical sense and handsome is is
attuned to this he's very interested in
making sure that when we use words in
more than one way we are cognizant to
the fact that we're doing that faith or
fides infant during my Christian faith
it has been used in multiple ways one
way is to talk about you know what we
might call the doctrinal the
propositional content you know really
what's been explored through the rest of
the Mona Logan you know the fact that
God is a Trinity that God is justice
itself those are things that you can say
in a person can of course understand
them but a person can also have faith
they can't read today they can believe
in them yeah those are not compatible or
that are not incompatible with each
other sorry some people do think that
they're not compatible with each other
but they are both compatible and hansoms
whole approach is to try to take what is
known by faith or believed in by faith
and then see if you can come to some you
know fuller rational exposition or
understanding of it so that sounds as if
faith is really sort of you know within
the realm of epistemology it has to do
with believing in things and
propositions that could either be true
or false and and perhaps we just accept
them rather than looking for proof or
things like that and some doesn't think
that faith is just that that's only a
component of faith faith also this is
you know what would be needed in order
to
faith as being anything like a virtue
faith has to be an orientation of the
person and so handsome is going to talk
here about you know the relationship
between faith and hope and love he says
you cannot actually love or hope for
what you don't believe so the question
then is what do we mean by belief it's
clear that that love and hope are in you
know intrinsically connected with
believing something we've already seen
that anthem has said that unless you
understand or remember something you
can't actually love it this is sort of a
lot of the same lines although we're
going to see there's more to it than
that same thing with hope if you if you
don't actually believe anything you
can't have hope in anything either so
what would be the thing that we believe
in it would be the supreme essence and
the nature of the Supreme essence and
its relations with created via these is
very you know abstract and then you know
of course we can sort of filter down to
much more particular statements of that
and ansem says that believing in the
supreme essence doesn't just mean
knowing some things about who are
believing that certain things are true
it's an orientation of the person he
calls us a striving a tendon a in Latin
so craigory intended a are connected
with each other and he uses a lot of
propositional discussions here that are
the some of these are sometimes lost as
we move it into English but let's let's
see what he actually has to say he says
I think the the same thing can be
signified fittingly and more briefly if
one says believe in using the landlord
in mean towards really the a divine
essence the supreme exist essence
instead of by believing to strive for in
supreme essence for if someone says that
he believes in him he seems to make it
quite clear both that he strives towards
on or onto odd in Latin the supreme
essence through the faith that he
professes and that he believes those
things that pertain to this striving for
someone who believes what does not
pertain to striving for than in him or
who does not strive on to you have in
virtue of what he believes does not
appear to believe in him and someone is
saying how do you know somebody believe
something they do something it's not
just they say something or they have
something in mind it is going to orient
their their decision-making it is going
to orient their their life in some way
so striving towards the the divine light
if you really think that God is the
supreme good then presumably and you
think that you know we can actually be
connected with God that thinking about
God is a way of connecting maybe you
would think about God quite often right
that would be one way in which we could
talk about it does also conclude this
component like it says about believing
in the things that are pertaining to
this struggle so you know if God tells
us you know for example through
revelation that were supposed to treat
each other well in certain ways and it
gives us some fairly specific
instructions like say in the Sermon on
the Mount or and you know various other
passages well presumably that would be
something that one would believe you
know it is true and one would believe
that one ought to act that way but then
you would actually have to act that way
you'd have to do it there's there's a
huge difference there and this is why
the distinction that he makes a little
bit later in chapter 78 it is so
important again it's not something a tad
some himself came up with Paul actually
in his letters talks about dad faith and
hey handsome is just picking up on this
and reinterpreting it in light of what
he's talking about so what
differentiates living faith from debit
faith or you might say faith in just
propositions and faith as something that
includes a striving he says with
whatever what however greatest certainty
so great a thing is believed faith will
be useless and like something dead
unless through love it is strong and
alive so now notice can't can't can't
have love unless you have hope you can't
have love or open less you have faith
but you can't really have faith unless
you also have love he doesn't talk about
you know the connection between hope and
faith as well but you presumably there
be something there so there's this
interconnection between them so he says
through long be too strong a lot the
thing that is accompanied and attended
by love will by no means the idol when
it has the opportunity to act when one
can make a choice instead it will exert
itself to act quite frequently which it
could not do without law we're talking
about the orientation towards the
supreme essence towards the Divine Being
towards the ultimate good you don't just
recognize it as the ultimate good if you
really do believe that it's the ultimate
good you love it and that means not just
sort of having a standoffish you know oh
I love you from afar you want to get as
close to the tech divine being as you
possibly can you want to be in
communication with it you want to be
connected with it if it's justice you
want to be connected with justice it's
goodness you want to be connected with
goodness and so on and so forth right so
Anselm goes on today says one who loves
the Supreme justice cannot disdain
anything just cannot turn against
justice or tolerate anything unjust so
therefore since whatever ass shows that
it is life without which
act it's not absurd to say an act of
faith is a living faith since it has the
life of love without which it would not
act what has faith that's Idol on the
other hand is not living he says it
lacks the life of love which it with
with which it would not be idle so he
goes on he says of faith that through
Baba's recognizes living a faith that
through disdain is his idol is proved to
be dead if you have read the you know
the scriptures inside and out and you
can you know track them out whenever you
want with proof texts for you know every
occasion and you actually believe what
you're saying but you don't do anything
and you don't have that love animating
you Ansel says that's dead faith that's
not going to do anything it's
interesting that you know you've got
this repository up in your head and you
you know that you have a attitude
towards it but the real test of whether
you do in fact believe in it is whether
you follow it whether you do it whether
you use it as your sort of ladder to
reach the divine so this is a really key
distinction when we talk about faith
hope and charity then what we're talking
about is living faith that is faith that
is animated by love we're talking about
a love that is made possible in part
because of the existence of the hope and
faith and we're talking about hope as
the opposite of despair so this is what
an some thinks the rational creature
ought to help